Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say'!
Do you know what to say when you want to check your understanding?
Listen out for useful language for checking your understanding.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
This isn't right.
Hey! Excuse me, Paul,
could you pass me the hammer?
Sorry, Bob, my ears are blocked.
I can't hear you very well.
Could you say that again, please?
The hammer.
Please could you pass it to me?
The spanner?
No. The hammer!
Sorry, Bob,
I don't understand. This is the spanner!
No, Paul, I need the hammer.
It's in the toolbox, on the left, under the scissors.
Sorry, Bob. Could you repeat that more slowly, please?
The hammer …
in the toolbox …
on the left …
under the scissors.
On the left … under the scissors …
Oh! Do you mean the hammer?
Is this it?
Yes, that's right!
Ah! Why didn't you say so?
I did!
Hello again!
Oh dear.
I think Paul needs to go home and sleep.
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for checking your understanding?
Listen to me and then repeat.
I'm sorry?
I can't hear you very well.
Could you say that again, please?
I don't understand.
Can you repeat that more slowly, please?
Do you mean the hammer?
Is this it?
Yes, that's right!
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you want to check your understanding in English.
Bye for now!